hello everyone bandit here as you no
doubt are well aware of by now
this week we just got a new sneak peek
at the highly anticipated sequel to
breath of the wild
and it looks like i was wrong about the
castle being a divine beast it's okay
it's all a part of the process
more importantly though since this
moment is way too big for one person to
handle a loan
i'm gonna have to call in a friend
[Music]
hello hey mr celtic how are you doing
yeah hi
um who is this it's masked nintendo
bandit
oh right masked nintendo banned it
i thought you're saying nintendo black
crisis wrong yep i get that a lot hey
listen i'm trying to cover the new
trailer that we just got for breath of
the wild too but it's proven to be a
real secret to everybody
would you happen to be up for a
collaboration to try to crack this thing
absolutely mate we all know it's
interesting
are you kidding me that would be an
absolute honor all right mate sounds
like a plan
cheers oh wait
how did you get this nut cheers what oh
don't look at me that way why do you
think they call me a bandit
to start things off let's make sure
we're all on the same page regarding the
relationship between hyrule castle and
ganondorf for nearly 30 years now hyrule
castle has been bound by the threads of
fate to the gerudo thief of legend
beginning in a link to the past
ganondorf manipulated his way into the
castle's throne room under the alter ego
known as agonym
in ocarina of time the man with the evil
eyes successfully captured and converted
the castle into his own magnificent lair
an
act of terror that he would later repeat
in twilight princess
now as of the recent trailer for the
sequel to breath of the wild that was
revealed to us this week at the e3
nintendo direct
we can see unmistakable proof that
ganondorf's corpse and his terrifying
malice have once again returned to
hyrule castle
although calamity gannon can be clearly
seen swarming around the castle for the
entirety of the first game
the notion that ganondorf himself or in
this case
ganondorf's corpse was also located at
the castle was debated before this new
trailer
since in the first trailer we couldn't
see exactly what was making the castle
rise above the ground
i mean some people thought it was
mechanical legs if you can believe that
this led some fans to theorize that
ganondorf's corpse could have been
positioned in a cave somewhere else
like the great plateau or the gerudo
desert however
since king rome told us in the first
breath of the wild that calamity gannon
appeared
deep below hyrule castle and we can now
see glowing red
tendrils of malice lifting the castle
from beneath the most
logical scenario is that ganondorf's
corpse has been positioned directly
underneath hyrule castle for an unknown
amount of time
but this fiery red malice in the new
trailer plays an even larger role than
just confirming ganondorf's position
the first image that flashes across the
screen is of our hero
link wearing the familiar blue clothing
from the first trailer
it appears that this goopy malice is
actually grappling onto his arm
and seems to be completely engulfing it
in stark contrast to link's arm glowing
green in the first
trailer however since the master sword
is sheathed on links back
in the first trailer and in his hand in
this new one
we can assume that the malice attached
itself to link after the glowing green
substance did
the fact that the malice grappled onto
the arm that link uses to wield the
master sword is
i believe a very key detail to solving
whatever it is that's happening here but
we'll return to that in a bit
because of the shots of zelda falling
into an abyss surrounded by rocks
the appearance of the corpse of
ganondorf link's brief wielding of the
master sword
and the lifting of the castle via
tendrils of malice
we can assume that all of these events
occur at the same time and place as the
original trailer
in other words at or under hyrule castle
brilliantly said i completely agree
about the location and those details you
pointed out regarding the master sword
in fact let's talk about that for the
rest of the trailer
we'll show new segments of gameplay both
on the ground in hyrule and in the sky
world above
now as far as talking about
possibilities for what the mysterious
floating sky world
is that's a topic for our other video
but what i want to focus on here is the
fact that as many fans have pointed out
so far
we don't see the master sword for the
remainder of the trailer this is
a huge detail because it implies many
things first it implies that the events
shown in the first
trailer and at the beginning of this one
must have happened before all
segments of gameplay shown to us this is
further reinforced by the fact that not
only does link not
have the master sword anymore but his
right arm is also shown to have already
been altered in the gameplay segments
which must have happened after the arm
altering events we've witnessed in both
trailers now second it implies that link
no longer has the master sword
because of the malice or in other words
that ganondorf sent his malice to attack
link because of the master sword
let's think about the situation real
quick you see link and zelda may have
been exploring a deep
dark unsettling cave but they were far
from helpless
remember zelda just unlocked her
superpowers that she used previously to
literally erase dark beast ganon from
existence
who by the way was a being made entirely
of pure
malice and as if that wasn't enough of a
counter to ganondorf's power already
she also just so happens to be
accompanied by one of the most bad to
the bone indestructible characters in
gaming history
link the hero of the wild has been
canonically proven to have faster
reflexes than a guardian laser and he
also just so happens to be wielding
the blade of evil's bane more than
capable of killing ganondorf
together this duo is literally the
invincible tried and true formula
that has been proven over and over to be
capable of defeating ganondorf and
in this situation they already have all
the tools necessary to do
just that but here's the thing that
changes the narrative
ganondorf knows that he's been defeated
before by past incarnations of this
exact same duo
and he's been sitting here thinking
about that for literally over
10 millennia which is more than enough
time to come up with a counter for this
very situation which is exactly what he
does
he removes zelda from the situation
first throws her down a chasm that we
cannot see the bottom of
and then as proven in this trailer he
removes the master sword from
link after which he stands up arms
raised almost as if posing victoriously
because his plan has come to fruition
lastly link not having the master sword
later on in the trailer
implies that since he last had it in the
castle it's still
in the castle with ganondorf it's enough
to send chills down your spine but
what's
even more chilling is what ganondorf
might have done with the sword
you see ganondorf is a schemer one of
the most
cunning that's ever been he's famously
been known for manipulating link and
zelda's heroic wills to his
favor as he did in ocarina of time when
he literally used link's drawing of the
blade of evil's bane
to let himself into the sacred realm the
fact that the very weapon that would be
used to defeat him was
key to his ultimate plan of obtaining
the triforce
can only be called a cruel irony and now
we're presented with ganondorf
easily casting zelda aside and removing
the master sword from link
the echoes of the past are beginning to
grow louder
and if ganondorf does in fact still have
the master sword with zelda removed from
the picture
and link venturing off elsewhere what
does this mean for the legendary blade
and also come to think of it what does
any of this have to do with the castle
i think what ties the master sword to
the castle in this ironic twist of fate
is directly related to the fact that
ganondorf raises the castle
only after his confrontation with link
and zelda
the big obvious question here is why
would ganondorf raise the castle
is it to distance himself from link and
zelda not gonna lie that seems
kind of trivial especially since one of
breath of the wild's main calling cards
was the fact that you can literally go
wherever you want to go whenever you
want to removing any linearity from
exploring the world around you
it seems odd to me that nintendo would
raise the castle out of reach and remove
this staple of what made breath of the
wild
so great and even led to it claiming the
game of the year award for 2017
and also if ganondorf was truly just
wanting to distance himself from the
heroes
why would he wait until they crept into
his lair before doing so
the only thing that makes complete
logical sense here would be if he held
off raising the castle because he needed
something
something he knew link and zelda would
eventually be bringing
straight to him and that would be either
princess zelda herself
or the master sword the two things that
he removed from the situation
in the trailer it's possible that he was
simply removing his two biggest threats
from the picture
but we can't rule out the fact that he
could also have something devious in
mind for one or both
of these two however even though this
answers why he waited to raise the
castle it still doesn't answer why he
raised the castle in the first place
it's likely that ganondorf raises the
castle not to create distance from
potential threats on the surface
but rather in order to gain access to
something after he has obtained either
the master sword
zelda or both one of the biggest
takeaways from the new trailer is
obviously the fact that there exists
this floating
island world above hyrule which is very
interestingly
not visible from the surface some have
been theorizing that this is because the
new sky worlds
and subsequently the green sash wearing
link are from the distant
past of hyrule 10 000 years ago but as
we can see in the trailer
both this alleged past link and current
link
are using the same paraglider which was
not seen in the first
game combine this with the fact that we
can actually see some portions of
present day hyrule from the viewpoint of
the sky islands
such as the giant trees of hyrule ridge
or the windmills in tanagar canyon
logically these tall trees would either
not exist yet
would not nearly be as tall and these
windmills which are made of wood
would also not exist 10 000 years ago
because of these factors i'm led to
believe that this is probably
present day hyrule which leaves us with
only two possible explanations for the
sky world's invisibility
one it could be obscured from the
surface by way of the cloud barrier that
highly set in the sky prior to the
events of skyward sword
or two it could be a different realm
entirely
in either circumstance it seems most
likely that ganondorf is raising the
castle to gain access to this sky world
and depending on what kind of realm it
is that might answer why he needed the
master swords
but that's a theory for another video my
video
actually which is live right now over on
his channel so be sure to check it out
in just a second because we're almost
wrapped up here
if you enjoyed this deep dive into the
implications of hyrule castle and the
master sword please consider dropping a
like below to get it spread around on
youtube and subscribe if you haven't
already for much more
zelda and nintendo content to come huge
huge thanks to the legendary celtic for
joining me on this one
yeah thanks so much for having me on
mate and thanks to all of you for
watching
as always humongous oh and bandit please
delete my phone number
will do sir as always humongous thanks
goes to everyone for watching
and of course to my fabulous bandit crew
of which i have
quite a few new names to announce please
say hello to green
link rj michael t solitaire theories
mr underscore dim gray danny b hylian
historian
and nicholas m who have all joined the
ranks of my elite
you guys take my breath away and are the
reason i can do
what i do if you watching are interested
in helping create these videos feel free
to click on that join button below or
follow the links in my description to my
patreon or merch pages
also down there are the links to my
social media pages so come follow me for
all the haps on twitter
that's all i've got for this one so as
always i hope you have a wonderful rest
of your day
this is masentina bandit looking forward
to seeing you again
and signing out
[Music]
you